مبروك مبروك
لكل السعوديين والعرب صقور الاخضر اليوم
فرحوا ملايين السعوديين والعرب بتحقيق فوز
تاريخي ومستحق عن جداره ضد الارجنتين في
اولى مباريات المنتخب في المونديال بهدفين
لواحد هاشتاجات المباراه ومن اول اليوم
كانت ترند لكن كان غالب عليها القلق
والترقب وبعد مباراه الناريه فعلا تالق
فيها منتخبنا الوطني بشكل مو عادي ولعب
لعب مو طبيعي الهاشتاجات ولعت اكثر واكثر
والاحتفالات زادت اكثر واكثر اولا
التوقعات كانت كلها معي للكفت الارجنتين
باعتباره انه منتخب كبير وحامل لللقب من
قبل وبيلعب فيه ميسي ثانيا بالفوز هذا
المنتخب السعودي اوقف سلسله اللا هزيمه
للمنتخب الارجنتيني او همم ستريك مثلا
اللي هو فوز مثل ما بيسموه
بشكل مستمر من 36 مباراه تحديدا طيب
المباراه فعليه كانت كبيره واداء منتخبنا
فعلا كان كبير ويستحقوا عليه كل تقدير
وهذا مو بس احنا كلامنا الفيفا غردت بعد
المباراه ووصفت اللي صار بانه احد اكبر
المفاجاه في تاريخ كاس العالم ومسي قال في
تصريح بعد المباراه نصا قال الهزيمه امام
السعوديه كانت ضربه قاسيه جدا
دربنا اخضر
قلبنا اخضر
فلنه اخضر
كلنا الاخضر
درب الاخضر
قلبنا خضر
خله اخضر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخضر
لمحه فا العالمين تفضل
وبعزه ارفع رايه بلادك
تنهرب
[موسيقى]
الناس اذنكم يا عيالنا
اقصهم يرسم طريقه ديالنا
وفراركم ضرب القلوب فن
يلا
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
متعوب
واستمتعوا
وارفعوا فينا الطموح والرفعوا فينا الصمود
اتعبوا لا تلعبون حرب الروح
[موسيقى]
ولا اصحابكم اصحابكم العب
وا وبعدين انتهاء المباراه انتشرت كمان
على المنصات مقطع وصور لولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان وهو بيتابع المباراه
وبيحتفل بالفوز
احتفال وضحك وتنكيت وناسه كلها مسيطره على
الهاشتاقات والسعوديين والعرب مولعين
تويتر بعض ابرز المتداول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دايما دموع دموع
كسرنا عينه بالسياره
[تصفيق]
ضد منتخب الارجنتين وليس لاعب واحد 11 ضد
11 ووعدنا ان شاء الله يوم الثلاثاء
[موسيقى]
تالقوا في التعليقات صراحه ويا رب تكملها
معانا ان شاء الله والاداء يكمل كده ونفوز
في المباريات الجايه ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]